welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by one fifth a query and the king
20% wait today in k7 relays already
joined by Anthony how are you doing well
I'm in London now you are here to
promote Anthony in the kitchen yeah
which is wait for it number two on the
New York Times bestseller list right now
but who is keeping tabs now because for
you would you say that cooking and food
go hand-in-hand with your South Karagias
would you say the biggest luxury now is
actually being in my own apartment
sleeping in my own bed cooking in my own
kitchen which that's the irony of the
life that I have now actually cook a lot
less than I used to and like connecting
with myself through food is probably
just focusing on one thing it's like the
best thing that I can do for myself and
your relationship with food guys hunters
have on the relationship your family
explained that journey to people out
there who might not already yeah so I my
dad especially we're both very obsessive
about food like we can be eating one
meal and talking about the next you know
we didn't all get along but like when we
sat around a table and like enjoyed a
meal together that was the one time
where we were all able to sort of break
bread and and have some laughs and have
some like nice positive time so well I
mean the last like 18 months for you
have been completely in the Sanitary
right I mean if they haven't been normal
no it's not a word I would use to
describe it it was almost like overnight
success for you wasn't it after years
and years of trying and trying and
trying
how did you adjust to that I think I'm
still trying to adjust to it like I only
started meditating a few weeks ago and
that was something that I haven't done
for years that a lot of friends might
have suggested that I do I like if I
walk into a room and I see somebody
who's like sad or upset I tend to take
on their feelings and I could sort of
like keep them if I get sad I stay sad a
lot longer than I need to same with like
happiness and so meditation is a good
way of kind of like setting myself up in
the morning if I do like 10 or 15
minutes and it just allows me to sort of
like allow the feelings to come but then
I let go of them like I don't have to
like hold on to things as much this past
week it's like we had cook book came out
New York Times bestseller Emmys flying
Londyn now flying a mantra it's like
there's always another thing on the
horizon and it and it gets challenging
sometimes like I really want to
appreciate every moment and like kind of
like embrace it and accept the fact that
if I get up and I'm feeling like I'm 60%
and I'm just gonna be a hundred percent
of that 60 percent I don't have to like
try to compensate or feel a certain way
it's just like it's all about acceptance
I think - what's your journey with your
own self-acceptance been like the first
thing that comes to mind is definitely
probably my Polish heritage that's
something that was a trickier one it
felt normal to be polish when I was
growing up and then I moved to West
Virginia and suddenly you know people
were asking about my name why was it so
weird why did I speak three languages
why was I bringing a lot of cabbage to
school for lunch suddenly like the
things that I kind of took for granted
or the things that were just Givens like
being Polish Canadians suddenly I felt
kind of like embarrassed about it
so I kind of pushed it away for the
while even to the point of like I almost
fully forgot polish and French and the
three years that I was there so it's
been this like sort of river of like
love/hate and and now I'm literally like
showcasing polish recipes and hangover
cures in my cookbook and it's sort of
like being polish is something that I'm
actually really proud of not just
accepting it but actually embracing it
and like honoring where I come from and
my ancestors and all that other stuff
how does it how does it make you feel to
be in that community and kind of feel
like an outsider
it's hard I mean it's it's really it's a
very strange thing to suddenly feel
embarrassed about something that you
never really paid attention to you get
socialized into being embarrassed about
things that you shouldn't be about and
for some people it's like body image
sexuality heritage I think it comes in a
lot of different forms and shapes when
did you start to deal with that I would
say when I actually met people in my
community who I can identify with I
think it's like attaching yourself to a
tribe or people with like-minded
interests I hear a lot about that in the
LGBTQIA community as well especially
like in the u.s. we have a thing called
GSA a Gay Straight Alliance and kids
feel a lot less lonely when they find
people who are like them so that they
don't feel like they're the only one
going through whatever it is that
they're going through do you think
sexuality made that harder for you or
did it make it a bit more comfortable
I think part of me if I'm fully honest I
always knew that I was interested in
guys but at the same time I had
relationships with women where I was
really happy and I was actually in love
with women so I knew it was one of those
situations where it was like when I find
the right one I'm gonna know it's time
and that happened maybe in like my early
mid-20s being bullied for being gay or
being called the F for it isn't
something that I really experienced
because it was just assumed that I was
straight even when I was in a long-term
relationship with a guy it was just I
worked at a restaurant for several years
and people just assumed I was straight
until he came in one day and it was like
oh yeah as a boyfriend
what made it more complicated was the
fact that I didn't feel comfortable
identifying as a certain title the idea
of like if you don't belong to a certain
group they don't have control over you
and you can be free to do whatever the
hell it is you want I listen to strange
music like I didn't listen to pop music
like all of my friends did I was always
into like the darkest Johnny Cash when I
was like 12 years old so like edgy
really yeah I'm edgy so I my interests
were always kind of different but I I
did enjoy that part I think with the
relationships it was kind of it was kind
of the same thing I knew that I didn't
want to be considered either like
bisexual or gay or hetero Sat like it
just didn't the closest thing I think is
just like queer or fluid if we're gonna
have to give it a name yeah I feel like
that's what the future is with talking
about your own experience has it helped
you overcome that stuff by talking about
it because you you said before you go to
therapy and do these things or if I have
something that I like a thought that I
have or something and I share it with my
therapist and then she'll be like oh
yeah like god this is actually a common
thing for guys your age to experience
this and suddenly it's like oh you
realize that you're not alone which i
think is kind of nice and humbling as
well especially in my early 20s and my
late teens I always thought like I'm the
only one who's experiencing what it's
like to have a family torn and like
child of divorce and like being fluid
and and whatever I was experiencing I
was always like oh like get me on the
cross like I'm the only one well I find
really amazing about you is you set this
thing to me when we spoke last time we
said I never used to post these
half-naked pictures until I came into
query and that was a weird adventure for
me anyway and I think the whole Internet
is firstly these tips
day in day out but what is your own
relationship with body image been like
throughout your whole life would you say
I think I was most comfortable with my
body when I was in a relationship with
women because there wasn't a sense of
comparison it's like we were different
and so I didn't really look at myself it
was my first relationship with a guy
where I kind of looked at myself and I
was like oh like my biceps aren't as big
as his and like my legs are longer like
I wish my torso were longer and since
the show came out I have like super cut
down on dairy on the amount that I that
I have and that's actually like changed
my body a lot and I'm somebody who loves
cheese but also being on camera all the
time it's suddenly like you see yourself
in an angle and it's sort of like what
is that chin line you know I have days
where I wake up and I just feel like
human garbage and I'm like bad like I
just eat vegetables and like try to eat
plant base and go to the gym twice in a
day and then I have days where I'm like
I'm feeling really good about myself I'm
gonna destroy two burgers today and
finish the day off with pizza and a
milkshake and maybe have a chocolate bar
that thing you just said about the body
is so interesting because I think that's
what's giving me a body complex is being
with boys because then you let you like
because you can do that direct
comparison right and it's such a mind it
is without even realizing because that's
I think a trick these days is that all
these people talk about like self-care
and self-love and like taking care of
yourself but I think that it's also
equally if not even more important to be
of service and to actually do something
for somebody else which is one story
which I would really want to bring up
actually where you talked about when you
did this episode with Tommy and it was
like the hardest thing for you to film
you said because you were going through
quite a lot of stuff at the time and she
said to you everybody calls me mama but
especially you need to call me mama and
then tan which she then picked you up at
the end of that day of filming and then
looked after you like what was that
narrative like for you we'd gone through
it was five months that we were living
in Atlanta we're away from our homes
sometimes you can like completely get
emotional over something that has
actually nothing to do with what you're
doing but it's just like excuse me like
everything kind of catching up with you
and just the thought of like the seasons
coming to an end looking back at like my
relationship with my
parents and my siblings it's like the
dynamics have shifted so much where I'd
be close with one one year and then
another I don't speak to one for a few
years and it's been like you know like
my father I wasn't close with him
growing up and now we speak several
times a day probably more often than we
should maybe not more than we should we
talk a right amount like that was a
mother who expressed pure unconditional
love and she didn't always and she's
somebody who like kind of changed her
mind and I also got emotional by the
fact that like there is something so
inspiring and the possibility of change
like we're all capable of changed what
do you think the shades to what you
bought brother heads I'd always wanted
to have a brother and I've I'd lied in
elementary school to several friends
mom's saying that my mother was pregnant
that I was gonna be a big brother well
like I always wanted to have a brother
it's the closest thing to it because it
is like family like we're all
experiencing this like weird phenomenon
together we are in it we get to vent to
each other we all experience Fame and
public life together and that's
something special like nobody can take
that away from you what do you think
they've taught you about yourself I was
very shy when I started doing the show
and I didn't necessarily feel I feel
like I'd tricked everyone into getting
on the show I wasn't enough of a chef I
wasn't gay enough and so I felt the need
to sort of prove myself and I would like
overcompensate with certain things I
never wanted to mistake cockiness with
confidence but now I think I understand
what the difference is a little better
and I can come into a room and I can
address my needs before I used to have
to pee before something and I wouldn't
say anything cuz I didn't want to upset
anyone and now I can just be like I
gotta go and I just go it's like simple
little things like that that I used to
like really put myself in like
tremendous amounts of discomfort so as
not to ruffle any feathers and now I'm a
lot more comfortable being like oh these
are my needs what do you think is the
thing that they've helped you free the
mice I think they just got me to be
fully comfortable with who I am and the
fact that like the confidence in knowing
that I don't have to try to be funnier
or be smarter like be honest and real
because that's sort of that's what we're
asked to do but anyone who's watching
this right now who is resonating with
the things you said most importantly
struggling to know who you are and stuff
acceptance what kind of message would
you want to
give to them what kind of advice I think
yeah if you're not if you're not
practicing self-acceptance and I feel
like it's you don't really know who you
are because if you get to know who you
are and what your interests are like
that should be good enough lean into
things that you're passionate about
whether it's music or food or anything
cultural or the people that you hang out
with I love how I love people I love
that I love being around people I tell
you what you mean because I get so much
stuff from my best friends like that I
want to see give me the passion totally
every single time that's those times
where they come over you know you put on
some Maggie Rogers light up a couple of
candles and just like whether it's
existential conversations or just
talking [ __ ] it's sort of like wow like
we're grownups and we get to a lot of us
have families and we get to have like
our chosen family and have our best
friends come over and hear about how
awful their week was and how they got
fired and what dysfunctional
relationship Cynthia's and again that
that's no shade towards Cynthia's I'm
not generalizing that Cynthia's are in
bad relationships but you know what I
mean we all have a Cynthia in our life
or we are Cynthia who knows I'm thinking
about the self-care that you were
mentioning before how that can be a
little selfish if you do too much of it
if you like lean in too much and just
remember that there are other people out
there that you should be connecting with
we're not meant to be alone 100% and he
doesn't love a good the existential chat
all right I love what I'll be someday
getting that little chat in there you go
well thank you so much for the Maine say
thank you for having and guys Anthony in
the kitchen out now available now get it
well it's hot for more glamour and
filters episodes of such inspiring
people as Anthony ding ding ding ding
that's me that's him make sure you
subscribe to the glamour UK channels now
we'll see you in two weeks for another
edition of glamour and filtered